la direction tout de suite l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
plus précisément la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de Guyancourt vous le
voyez on retrouve sur place Régine
raleges de la rédaction de TV 78 puisque
l'UVSQ Régine et son président font ce
soir leur vœux 2023
bonsoir Grégory alors oui effectivement
ce soir c'est la cérémonie des vœux et
j'ai avec moi monsieur Alain buis le
président d'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonsoir alors
ce soir vous allez prononcer vos vœux
c'est un moment important pour clore
l'année 2022 c'est également important
pour 2023 comment est-ce que vous
abordez justement cette nouvelle année
et qu'est-ce que vous retenez également
de l'année 2022 le sujet important c'est
la finalisation de la construction de
l'Université Paris Saclay avec
l'intégration pleine et entière de
l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans ce grand
projet sur lequel nous travaillons déjà
depuis plus de 10 ans
justement et vous avez un grand projet à
l'horizon 2025 c'est la fusion de
l'université paris-saclet c'est à Nice
qui a de grandes étapes justement à
franchir quant à ce projet là c'est
exactement ce que nous avons commencé en
2022 et qu'on va confirmer en 2023 alors
nous sommes pas dans un une logique de
fusion classique au sens du terme et
donc on l'appelle on a précisé
exactement que le devenir de
l'Université de versa 50 ans divine dans
le cadre de Versailles de Paris Saclay
et donc ce sera une intégration pleine
et entière donc on va conserver nos
campus et on va changer nos statuts et
on va aussi changer notre nom et donc on
est on y travaille donc on s'appellera
Université Paris Saclay tiré quelque
chose qui représentera forcément
Versailles et les Yvelines par exemple
qui n'est pas encore défini aujourd'hui
mais c'est très important donc ça montre
le côté irréversible quelque part de
notre participation projet Paris Saclay
aujourd'hui c'est la date anniversaire
du lancement du premier nano satellite
uvsq7 il a été lancé il y a deux ans
donc le 24 janvier 2021
second est prévu en avril est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
oui alors c'est effectivement deux ans
en fait c'est exactement le jour pour
jour 2 ans le lancement de ce premier
nano satellite un projet universitaire
et le second avec la même équipe donc je
rappelle du laboratoire l'Atmos ici qui
a l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est juste
derrière ici et le lancement la mission
orbite aura lieu très bientôt et
probablement dans les toutes prochaines
semaines donc je sais pas encore au
briser quelle date mais c'est imminent
donc c'est vraiment une grande fierté
qui symbolise la capacité à notre
université d'être très proactive au
niveau de la recherche
merci beaucoup Alain vie et je rappelle
vous êtes le président de l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
présente ses vœux ce soir à la
bibliothèque universitaire à Guyancourt
merci Régine Rollès avec Céline Charlot
au moyen technique depuis la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de Guyancourt
de l'UVSQ